leur a passé 14 ans de sa vie enfermé à
guantanamo sans charges contre lui et
certainement le prisonnier le plus
longuement torturé
mohamedou ould slahi est un citoyen
mauritanien qui a été arrêté au
lendemain du 11 septembre
suspecté d'être d'avoir été
l'organisateur des attentats du 11
septembre
ce qui n'est pas le cas
[Musique]
au maroc amélie people get right un ring
de boxe
[Musique]
ma famille est venue pour on a été levée
pour notre french state un trio africain
stander l'a10 my family guy laquerre
manitoba nicheuses à youssou go to
school
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
athena positive ou négative 1,0 en
rythme annuel à 313,9 six robots staff
sédatives morumbi la forme at il un big
thing un slip de profession you know you
can at six défaites seventies
ces vins qu'il aimait faire serait
d'aider straight no sleep tony for abba
interdite
[Musique]
ce qui agace et beaucoup moins et doué
il avait beaucoup de mal avec ça c'est
que pour elle l'important c'était pas
qu'ils soient ils ne sont ou pas mais
qu'ils avaient droit à une défense et
lui il mourrait dans vie de leur faire
comprendre qu'il était innocent ou du
coup ils ont eu pas mal de deux conflits
et des changes un petit peu musclé et
jusqu'à ce que qui révèle un peu tout ce
qui s'est passé et ça a changé les
choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la classe et heavy hauling rachète des
we go staff ait pris peur
[Musique]
on y sort de guantanamo il sort de
prison et sort d'une prison concrètes
pour se retrouver dans une prison à ciel
ouvert en or et annie bloqués c'est à
dire que son passeport avait été
récupérée par les autorités
mauritaniennes n'avez pas le droit de
voyager encore actuellement quand il
essaie d'avoir un visa dans un pays
européens notamment l'allemagne où vit
sa femme et son enfant sa femme qui est
avocate américaine
il n'obtient pas de visa
[Musique]
il n'a certainement pas la notoriété des
des deux héros que je vais citer mais il
est fait du même bois
ils ont la même grandeur et la même
sagesse pour moi c'est un mélange entre
mohamed ali et nelson mandela